hello, how are you, sali jaramillo greets you
with your informative brief for today monday
april 12 today the
clark county fire department inaugurates a
station east of the valley and to
celebrate this occasion the staff is
providing doses of the jones
minions vaccine at this station  It is located
around 9 near the sting control cross.
These vaccines will be given on a
first-come, first-served basis from half past one
to half past three in the afternoon.
Theme opens applications for
funeral assistance starting
today families can obtain up to nine
thousand  dollars to cover these
funeral expenses to qualify a
death certificate is required stating
the person died due to comic book 19
also these expenses must reflect that
they were made after January 20 of
last year families must show
all receipts for expenses
and  starting May 2 if you
collect unemployment you must show the
department that you are looking for work
That's right, applicants must have a
weekly job search record
to continue obtaining these benefits.
This step is possible after the expiration of the
executive order granted by
Governor Celso, which in March
2020 we now pass with the
weather forecast, another day of the same is expected.  that yesterday
temperatures in the high 80s and
light winds for tomorrow the temperatures will begin to drop
and the winds will
return to the valley have a good day
I am salt and jaramillo and this was your
brief informative for disney in Spanish
[Music]